[Music]
what comes to mind at the mention of
apple
some of the most commonly used products
of course the iphone
ipad and mac it's likely you're
currently using an apple device
the largest apple manufacturing factory
is the foxconn technology group's
zhengzhao branch the company's
headquarters lined to chang
new taipei city taiwan tirigao a
taiwanese tycoon
established foxconn in 1974. according
to forbes terry is worth 6.5 billion
dollars and has been christened
taiwan's donald trump while foxconn has
provided job opportunities for numerous
people
it's been marred by controversy i know
you're curious to find out the details
so let's descend inside apple's largest
factory in china welcome back to our
channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
so you never miss an upload from us
inside the production plant
the largest foxconn factory lies in
longhua town
shenzhen many workers work at the
longhua science and technology park
enclosed campus
often called the foxconn city the
mammoth production plant occupies a
record 15 million square feet
you'll be surprised to learn that the
production plant manufactures
approximately half of all the apple
devices globally
out of its ability to produce up to 500
000 iphones daily
the company earned itself the name the
iphone city the factory covers
approximately 1.2 square meters or 3
kilometers
and features swimming pools 15 factories
a television network known as foxconn tv
and a fire brigade you'll also find a
center with restaurants
a bank a grocery store a hospital and a
bookstore
many of the staff at the factory work 12
hours daily six days a week just so you
know
some u.s cities have fewer people than
the workforce at the foxconn factory in
zhengzhao you're probably shocked at
that statement but it's actually true
you may be wondering where all those
workers live dorms are available in
between 10
and 20 story buildings suppose you've
worked in a factory before
in that case you know that a team of
vendors and entrepreneurs usually
establish shops nearby to make some
money from selling street food
multiple products and giving massages up
to 1.3 million employees earn revenue
from the foxconn plant in china
so far the company is the biggest
private employer
in china in 2007 foxconn started
manufacturing apple gadgets
since then the company has faced one
accusation after the other
these range from staff complaining about
horrible working conditions to labor
abuses
and severe penalties for workers when
they make mistakes
foxconn experienced different suicides
among its workers between 2010
and 2011. both foxconn and apple had to
make some changes at the production
center to control the situation
of course no company wants to lose its
reputation
and will salvage it before the condition
worsens now you should know that many
big companies rely on some government
support to remain afloat
in this case the government has been
instrumental in supporting the company
through tax incentives
support and subsidies to maintain
zhengxiao production from the assistance
foxconn receives from the government
they have built power plants and new
roads leading to the factory
they've also managed to pay
transportation and energy costs
foxconn also takes advantage of the
assistance they receive from the
provincial
government to settle export target
bonuses that totaled 56 million dollars
in 2016.
for a company that big they need lots of
effort from the government the province
has set regulations covering the number
of employees from local cities and
villages working in the factory
sometimes when work gets overwhelming
the company receives additional workers
from governmental coal companies
according to the financial times trade
schools send students from the age of 16
to work at foxconn to acquire work
experience
which would help them graduate just
before the iphone 10 was released in the
market
reports show that numerous students
worked overtime at the company and
perhaps you know someone who works there
but did you know that this action is
illegal under chinese regulations
speaking to the times in 2016 lu me who
heads a private recruiting company in
zhengzhao
said every city's department of labor
and ministry of human resources
is involved what does a typical daily
schedule at foxconn look like workers
wake up
at 6 30 a.m and report to the factory at
7 00 am
staff should eat breakfast and be seated
at their work positions at 8am
lunch lasts an hour with many staff
preferring to eat at the available
hotels inside
foxconn however a few teams opt for the
vendors outside campus because the meals
are better the shift would end at 5 pm
but sometimes staff receives an offer to
work extra hours
often getting off the clock between 8
and 10 pm
in the evening after work staff is free
to engage in dinner together with their
friends
interested parties can even play video
games before retiring to bed at 11 pm
this schedule remains unchanged unless
staff has to work during the night shift
what personal experiences do employees
working at foxconn have
i know you identify better with stories
from real experiences
so here it goes one worker said she
works on 1700 iphones daily
this roughly translates to 12 iphone
screens for hours across the day
other workers that specialize in
fastening chipboards may need a minute
for each iphone completing around 700
pieces per day
while foxconn workers find their work
repetitive and boring
they admit that it is not overwhelming
amid the accusations of foxconn faces
many people enjoy working there
especially the natives of hanon
leo a local vendor and previous worker
at the production center
says people like to work at this factory
because you are close to your family if
you are from hanan
you get sundays off and you can go home
and visit your family that's the perk
leo also mentions that high pay and
minimal pressure are reasons why many
employees will not leave yet with
numerous repetitive factory jobs
available the workers do not have to
struggle while working
life at the zhongzhao factory is as
living in the villages
think about everything that happens back
in the village some employees waste
their free time away browsing on their
smartphones
many workers at foxconn zhengzhao
factory are in their 20s
giving the environment a scholarly
feeling most of them have been working
there for nearly a year
except for a few commemorating two years
which they say is an eternity
many workers will leave after the first
year due to boredom and lack of interest
of course once you're not motivated
quitting is the only option
unlike many working stations workers
here don't apply for particular roles
instead you're assigned to the
department where more people are needed
some departments like inventory control
are more relaxed than others allowing
employees to eat their bread anywhere
this is some good news for bread lovers
but so you know the more formal the
department the more
overtime opportunities you get you'll
even stand a chance of getting a higher
salary
one worker who earns 470 dollars per
month working as a clerk says
although they can make up to about 5 000
yuan per month which is quite high in my
eyes i feel that these workers are not
in good health because of all the
overtime
repetitive tasks at the zhongzhou
factory are the order of the day
and probably why many workers leave
after a year on this matter
chen a worker here said eventually i
felt annoyed to the core of my heart
like i had no purpose but the good thing
is you can always quit for a better job
at will
not everyone can leave though many
workers at the assembly line have
families to provide for
and leaving is never an option
surprisingly many workers don't know
that a better opportunity could mean
working fewer hours for a better salary
or doing less monotonous tasks
working here is neither better nor worse
for some of them all they do is make a
living
and they feel like the conditions are
but the same in all factories but these
views represent only a few of them you
should know that the workforce is large
and everyone's opinions and experiences
vary for example
some workers complain about not getting
enough sleep due to the alternating
shifts
while others are comfortable many
workers at the fox con
zhengzhao factory and others in china
complain about the living conditions
in 2012 some foxconn employees protested
for overcrowded dorms
sanitation conditions and inadequate
meals workers who can't stand the dorms
or those with families have the option
of renting a one-bedroom apartment but
these are slightly costly which is why
only a few do so with all this
information
perhaps you'd want to work inside the
largest apple factory if an opportunity
knocked or maybe not
leave us a word in the comments section
we'd love to hear from you